baseball
you said something yesterday right you
said something yesterday about
baseball's and baseball is the most
boring sport and they're using audience
why right yep did you have a reason for
it or were you just asking because you
wanted to know well there's so I started
looking at the the revenue that comes in
for Major League Baseball and I was
actually surprised how little of it is
actually television right or is is the
tickets that are that are sold and a lot
of it's television rights but the
reality is who enjoys watching baseball
on television anymore it's a small
minority of the population I think
they're they have to find a way to sexy
it up there has to be something and so I
was asking Pat because we all know that
he has the entrepreneur the
entrepreneurial mind what could be done
to baseball - I don't know bring back
the mystique to bring back the fun make
baseball great again what can we do okay
because baseball is great but it's very
very boring do you know why you know why
baseball is boring
tell me why is baseball boring do you
actually know or know you don't know
slow part today slow and long why is it
boring and slow and long today it's
become a pitcher's duel let me tell you
I never went to a game to watch Ana
saying oh my gosh 1-0
hell yeah what a great game great game
you went to again me you want to see
what home run to see home run we need to
bring back every Rhodes
we're going to bring back this by the
way yeah make steroids great yeah as
crazy as that sounds to you that's crazy
as that sounds doesn't sound that crazy
every team's value would go up if there
were more home runs if there's more home
runs they'd be more accepting behind it
but right now it's more of a math that's
like you go to see NBA you want to see
scoring you don't want to see an 81 79
games with us
did you watch this year's NBA all-star
game in February did you watch it did
you really miss it don't tell me you
missed I watch I want to look I watched
a dunk contest I watched just close
combat did you watch the all-star game
they don't play defense it's just fourth
quarter
Adam they play D in the fourth quarter
then they change into the fourth quarter
that's right
greatest DHA nine the fourth quarter
that's right - right you're absolutely
right the greatest you're right
quarter up every seat in the history of
absolutely right I could not believe it
and who won LeBron's team what the whole
thing was about defense yes I'm just in
the fourth quarter was sick the right
the first team to get one fifth while
you were two five or someone awesome
the motto BJ so here what's the point
there here's the point the NBA all-star
game for the longest time has been
boring what are you watching it for no
one plays defense that's a lob you throw
it around and say ah who cares who wins
this year they change it up
I think MLB needs to sit down just like
a sales organization needs to change a
compensation structure sometimes yeah I
think the MLB needs to first fire Rob
Manfred was the worst freaking
commissioner out there 60 games they're
talking about the fact that even in the
games it can be six feet within each
other you yet you literally are going to
get ejected if you come six feet from
another player for the terms or the the
umpire like to go argue a call if you
come within six feet you're
automatically ejected with get this a
suspension and a fine now in a 60 game
season start thinking about how
important a suspension is like if you're
out for five games or ten games like
that's that so usually you get suspended
60 games for steroids so you know you
get a car you're out for the whole
season I don't know I think they need to
change the compensation structure in
there in the game of baseball and what I
mean by that is the way the game is set
up right now it's too slow kids are not
going to like I had a buddy of mine this
guy is all about baseball and he's all
about pitching we go to a game and it
says this is a great pitching game wow
what a great game we're at I'm like what
a great what a nurse sixth inning and
it's zero zero this is a ten no no no
watch this look at the strategy look at
the pitch they've already switched two
times and look what they're doing the
guys still throw in a 98 I said I don't
care about a 98 mile fastball you know
what I care about I care about a 450
foot home run that's what I care about
beat it we're gonna get some tightness
here about the but you know it would go
up and beyond my mom went to a game one
time to the Texas Rangers play the
angels back in the days the angel said
salmon and a ranger said Juan Gonzalez
at this game
Gonzalez hit two homeruns at this hero
your favorite play favorite baseball
player two home runs
you remember those types of game now you
can't remember a pitching duel when it
comes down to baseball they got to
figure out a way to change the pitching
game
[Music]